[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous si vous voulez bien venir
avec moi je vais vous emmener en voyage
je vais vous demander de fermer vos yeux
et d'imaginer nous sommes en 2100 les
températures ont augmenté de 4 à 5
degrés sur toute la surface du globe
la calotte glaciaire a fondu entraînant
la montée des océans
la plupart des villes côtières ont
disparu les îles englouti sous les eaux
les tsunamis ouragans se déchaînent
partout nous voyons alors nos enfants et
nos petits enfants vivre le drame que
nous leur avons légué en héritage
nous nous souvenons alors de toutes ces
campagnes de sensibilisation de tous ses
accords des efforts à fournir pour aller
vers une économie d'énergie pour aller
vers une consommation verte durable et
renouvelable
mais surtout surtout l'abandon des
énergies fossiles
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux forte
heureusement nous sommes le 7 décembre
nous sommes à l'institut français et je
suppose que tout comme moi vous êtes
heureux d'être ici et non dans cette
projection de 2100 et qu'au sortir de
cette conférence vous décidiez tous
d'être des acteurs du changement
c'est nécessaire pour que les
générations futures n'est pas à vivre le
drame que nous venons de vivre
je voudrais préciser que je ne m'adresse
pas à vous en tant qu'experte parce que
je ne le suis pas mais nous vivons dans
une époque fabuleuse où nous pouvons
avoir accès aux travaux de ces experts
pour le peu qu'on se donne la peine
d'aller chercher de l'information
alors je veux vous parler de l'homme
l'homme il est devenu un super-héros
en 150 ans seulement il a réussi à
devenir une force géologique
il a déréglé un système climatique
pourtant stable depuis des millénaires
l'homme abusent des énergies fossiles
pétrole gaz charbon et non content de se
faire consumer la planète
il persiste à détruire la seule solution
naturelle qui pourrait sauver l'humanité
les forêts chaque minute
c'est l'équivalent de 27 stade de
football qui sont rasés de la surface du
globe
nous savons tous que l'arbre n'est pas
sur terre uniquement pour faire joli non
l'arbre est l'essence même de nos vies
pour vivre nous respirons et la forêt
est le poumon du monde
mais ce n'est pas que ça la baisse celui
qui filtre les eaux de pluie qui
stockent le carbone qui tempère le
climat qui sert à la médecine mais aussi
les créateurs d'emplois alors la forêt
ce n'est pas uniquement cette immense
régulateur biologique géologique
climatique etc
c'est aussi ce que nous devrions laisser
aux générations futures pour assurer
leur survie
il faut que savoir que la déforestation
a toujours existé plus ou moins
concentrés en fonction des époques au
xviie siècle par exemple les etats-unis
ont perdu plus de 90% de leurs forêts
primaires en europe c'était plutôt au
moyen âge alors que danser sur cette
partie du monde
la tendance est à l'augmentation par
exemple la france qui a récupéré 10 % de
ses forêts c'est maintenant que les
forêts tropicales subissent de plein
fouet la déforestation de 16 millions
d'hectares en 1960 à 7,8 millions en
à 3,4 millions en 2015 aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus que moins de 2 millions
d'hectares de forêts dans notre pays
les forêts ivoiriennes sont donc en
grand danger mais par ricochet la survie
de sa population
il faut savoir que lorsque une espèce
végétale disparaît plus de 30 espèces
animales disparaissent également alors
comme plusieurs d'entre vous j'ai
entendu les discours des écologistes
mais aussi ceux des climato-sceptiques
et comme certainement la plus grande
partie je me suis dit qu'à mon petit
niveau je pouvais rien changé j'ai
continué ma petite vie en écoutant sa
d'une oreille jusqu'au jour où il ya
deux ans je fais un gros burn out
et quand par intuition
je décide d'aller guérir mon âme dans la
nature je me met alors en totale
immersion pendant trois mois dans une
forêt du nord de la france et je me
rends compte là à quel point la forêt
bénéfique à l'être humain
alors je décide à ce moment là que ma
vie prenne un tournant et de me
consacrer à dame nature et ses soldats
les arbres alors j'apprends à partir de
travaux d'experts parce que du coup je
commence à me documenter que la forêt
est la première solution naturelle pour
faire face aux ravages du réchauffement
climatique
je continue de lire
j'apprends qu'il faudra planter des
milliards d'arbres
waouh on a tous appris à planter des
arbres à l'école on sait que c'est long
on sait que c'est harassant on devine
que c'est coûteux et là je me dis non
non non non non langue c'est un super
héros il est même allé sur la lune
il devrait pouvoir trouver une solution
je continue de chercher et là je tombe
sur un documentaire et le titre
m'accroche en afrique ils ont trouvé la
solution au boisement
ah bon je regarde ça chamboule ma vie
parce que je découvre quelque chose
d'extraordinaire bill morrison a dit
face au problème de plus en plus
complexe de notre monde
les solutions restent honteusement
simple quand je découvre ce documentaire
je veux dit non c'est pas possible il ya
une arnaque quelque part c'est trop
simple je continue de chercher et je
découvre que c'est une technique
ancestrale
elle existait dans l'egypte antique on
en a même trouvé des traces au moyen
orient en afrique du nord
ensuite ça disparaît et pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale il y à un
botaniste jean japonais qui le remet à
l'ordre du jour alors ce japonais
s'appelle masanobu fukuoka et d'ailleurs
la technique porte son nom il décide de
se consacrer à cette nouvelle technique
il est né en 1908 et il a écrit beaucoup
de travaux que vous pouvez trouver sur
internet notamment la révolution d'un
brin de paille qui est un qui est un
best-seller et qui pourraient vous
apporter beaucoup de choses et ebuzz
c'est travaux sur le fait que très
souvent dans les travaux agricoles
l'intervention humaine exige des efforts
inutiles
il est formel là dessus et donc il
il accentue c'est c'est ça c'est
principe sur la non-intervention la très
faible intervention de l'homme dans la
nature
ces principes sont donc élémentaire et
relève même du bon sens premièrement il
faut pas labourer
deuxièmement il faut pas mettre
d'engrais alors ça c'est tellement
simple parce qu'on se dit les forêts qui
existait avant qu'on arrive sur terre
avait personne pour leur mettre de
l'engrais ensuite il faut pas taillé
parce que plus il ya de plantes plus la
biodiversité riche il faut pas arroser
les besoins en eau des plantes doivent
être satisfaits par la pluie
il conçoit alors
décide boels comme vous pouvez
l'entendre
ça se compose de sites boys bâle de
graines
alors les balles de graines comme vous
les voyez là sur le la photo c'est une
balle dans laquelle il ya une graine et
tout autour des nutriments
alors cette balle on va se dire mais
pourquoi ne pas jeter directement la
graine dans la terre quand vous faites
comme ça les animaux ont tendance à
manger les graines donc le site boys
il est dans une coque de protection qui
empêche les animaux de les manger mais
aussi qui leur empêche par exemple de
brûler si un incendie ou que les vents
les les places alors vous n'avez rien
d'autre à faire quand vous avez un site
bolt dans la main que de le poser le
jeter ou le lancer dans la nature là
vous avez envie que ça germes
il ne faut juste pas les enterrer donc
la graine et la l'abri de dents et elle
est elle attendra juste son heure
lorsqu'il va avoir le dernier maillon
manquant c'est à dire l'eau là où les
cibles sont intéressant c'est qu'ils
permettent d'en semences et des zones
inaccessibles à l'être humain
bon on se dira si on a envie de planter
des arbres dans le plateau y a pas
besoin de mettre des sites vol on peut
faire du plant in normal ils permettent
donc dans semences et des zones des
grandes zones parce que vous pouvez avec
des moyens aériens par exemple des
hélicoptères ou des où des drones en
semences et de grandes surfaces
rapidement en une journée des milliers
de sites bold peuvent être largués sur
des super grande surface voilà c'est
ingénieux n'est ce pas
alors merci nous avons déjà des preuves
que la technique fonctionne d'abord pas
existe parce que ça existe dans
plusieurs pays du monde
mais en particulier en afrique alors il
ya une société kenyane qui a un peu la
tête de file du mouvement qui existe
depuis 2016 et qui a un tel succès
d'ailleurs cette semaine ils ont fait la
une de cnn il ya un mois leonardo
dicaprio qui était un grand con con
bateau pour l'écologie a parlé de ça ils
ont eu un tel succès que nous avons
voulu nous former auprès d'eux nous
avons donc pu bénéficier d'une formation
technique et nous avons commencé il ya
un an à faire nos essais ici en côte
d'ivoire au départ je pensais que je
pouvais acheter des sites boys au kenya
et les faire venir en côte d'ivoire mais
en fait c'était pas bon parce que chaque
univers doit respecter son écosystème
nous devrions donc le fer avec des
graines de chez nous alors après les
premiers tests échec comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer nous n'avons pas laissé
tomber
on a continué à s'améliorer jusqu'à ce
que le 29 mars 2019 on est nos premiers
sibold de teck qui germe
voilà je sais pas si vous voyez la
graine vous voyez bien les racines qui
sortent même avant que le avant de voir
le la graine germée alors laventure
cibole se met alors en marche et notre
principal objectif est d'aider au
reboisement de notre pays les besoins
sont énormes
le ministère m'a dit 300 millions
d'arbres par an pendant 10 ans pour
recouvrer 20% de notre couvert forestier
alors imaginez s'il faut planter 300
milliards d'arbres avec la technique que
tout le monde connaît
tenez on va faire un petit petite
comparaison planting classique site
balling premièrement il vous faut faire
une pépinière
ça va vous mettre facilement quatre à
six mois
là où avec les sites vol en une semaine
on en fabrique
deuxièmement imaginé il ya tout un
process dans le plant in classique du
défrichage jusqu'à la transplantation
c'est à dire le moment où vous mettez le
plan dans le trou là où avec les sea
dogs
on n'a qu'à les jeter dans la nature
troisièmement avec le plant in classique
en objet de tenir compte de certaines
saisons entend aujourd'hui la plus de
saison donc s'il faut attendre des
saisons on est mal barré là où avec les
sea dogs
on peut les jeter dans la nature à tout
moment de l'année ils attendront juste
d'avoir de l'eau c'est un gain
incroyable de temps la pénibilité de la
tâche est complètement annulé et enfin
planting classique on comprend tout de
suite
pépinière sachet noir de sachets noirs
après il va dans la nature on sait pas
combien de centaines d'années polluer
les océans etc
est-ce que vous avez compris à quel
point le site bowling est une méthode
intéressante elle permet nous rouvrons
forestation rapide économique
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là nous
fabriquons les sea dogs à la main on
s'est plaint des énergies fossiles donc
on ne va pas aller en mécanisée le
système et polluent encore plus alors
ces milliers de sites balls qui doivent
être faire la main ça nécessite de la
main d'oeuvre et nous avons la
possibilité de faire travailler des
femmes des jeunes des communautés
villageoises qui n'ont pas de
qualification mais qui peuvent
travailler et gagner leur vie décemment
voilà alors nous avons sillonné la côte
d'ivoire depuis six mois nous avons
répandu plus de 600000 site volz la plus
grande partie s'est faite par le
ministère des eaux et forêts mais nous
avons eu des ong qui sont venus vers
nous et bien sûr nous mêmes je vais vous
raconter l'histoire d'un petit village
qui m'a touché ils sont venus nous voir
donc le vise le village s'appelle taux
mid à nous ils sont dans la région du
moronou
ils sont venus nous voir en nous disant
nous voulons reboiser
un hectare de forêt mais nous n'avons
pas les moyens là nous avons une fête
qui s'appelle la fête de la lumière
depuis que nous existons c'est en 2019
que nous avons l'électricité alors nous
faisons trois jours de fête pendant
lesquels nous voulons faire du
reboisement et en face on avait des
étudiants étrange ivoiriens à l'étranger
qui ont ouvert une cagnotte en ligne et
qui nous ont dit non on a envie de
participer au reboisement du coup ils
ont récolté 685 euros à peu près ça
faisait quatre cent cinquante mille nous
avons provisionné pour pouvoir offrir au
village de tommy danu qui a fait son
redressement grâce au site bol le 15
novembre
et comme par hasard ça tout tombait le
jour de la journée de l'arbre donc ils
ont fait une bonne action
grâce à ces étudiants nous avons essayé
d'introduire un nouveau concept que nous
appelons du reboisement participatif en
fait qu'on veut que tout le monde puisse
participer
alors on élimine personnes on a créé un
hashtag qui savent elles plantent à
forest et qui nous donne du baume au
coeur de dire aux gens venez avec nous
tout le monde peut participer au
reboisement
on ne l'attend plus des gens qui qui à y
planter mille arbres en une journée mais
tous ensemble en se mettant tous
ensemble on peut y arriver
voilà il faut il faut savoir que c'est
les experts qui le disent encore une
fois que l'être humain vivant 2-0 à 70
ans consomment l'oxygène émis par 5000
arbres alors il est demandé à chacun de
nous au cours de sa vie de planter au
moins 5000 arbres pour ne serait-ce que
rendre à la nature ce qu'elle vous a
donné gracieusement mais aussi permettre
aux générations futures de pouvoir avoir
ce que vous avez et nous avons beaucoup
de chance de réaliser que nous vous
prouve que nous pouvons encore agir nous
sommes la première génération à vivre
les effets du réchauffement climatique
mais nous sommes surtout la dernière
génération à
pouvoir y apporter des solutions alors
si vous n'avez ni sibbles ni pépinière
mais que vous avez des graines
souvenez vous qu un arbre c'est avant
tout des graines
vous pouvez planter vos graines sur 10
il y en aura au moins trois qui
germeront enfin je voudrais terminer par
une citation du docteur mcpherson qui
dit si vous pensez que notre
environnement est moins important que
notre économie
essayer d'arrêter de respirer le temps
de compter votre argent je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]